este balance tiene un sabor mucho más
agrio por las proyecciones del fondo
monetario internacional que prevé que la
economía británica la única dentro de
los poderosos países del g7 se contraerá
este 2023 desde hace tres años cuando se
hizo efectivo el divorcio con la Unión
Europea ha habido escasez de alimentos
frescos provenientes de Europa por
supuesto los precios de estos se han
incrementado y también hay falta de
escasez de mano de obra según el diario
El financial Times ese hueco laboral
sería de al menos 330.000 personas pero
también por el brexit ha habido aumento
de la burocracia y nuevos trámites que
han afectado tanto importadores como
exportadores en este momento Londres y
Bruselas están tratando de renegociar el
protocolo de Irlanda del Norte que se ha
convertido en el nuevo punto de tensión
entre las partes y que creó una nueva
frontera comercial en el mar de Irlanda
Además de que el gobierno regional
escocés Está tratando de encontrar el
camino jurídico o político para
adelantar un segundo referéndum de
Independencia Pese a que ya el gobierno
central en Londres ha dicho en repetidas
oportunidades que esa consulta no será
posible para marcar esta fecha en
Twitter el Primer Ministro Richie sunak
dijo que gracias al brexit el Reino
Unido ha recuperado sus libertades y
dijo además que este país el Reino Unido
ha podido ser muy exitoso en el
lanzamiento de las vacunas más rápido
contra el covid 19 en Europa que ha
firmado acuerdos comerciales con más de
70 países y recuperado el control de sus
fronteras